[Music]
hi everyone thank you so much for
joining us this afternoon my name is
Vanessa July and I'm a cloud customer
engineer for a higher education at
Google that means that I work with
customers like yourselves on
applications that touch the student body
the staff and an institution and and
even sometimes in use cases like
distance learning and online learning so
today you'll hear from a little bit for
me on what Google's vision for an AI
first institution looks like we'll talk
most of the time actually you'll be
hearing from people just like yourselves
at institutions who have implemented
some of this technology and what that
was like what that experience was like
for them and in some of these cases that
came out of that and potentially even
some of the roadmap opportunities that
exist for those institutions so I think
a lot of us here know that the path for
a student from perspective all the way
to employed professional is not one step
and so Google really took this to heart
and we think of it and translate it into
a student life cycle and what that means
is there are so many places along a
student journey that we can interject
with technology and we think about how
we can use technology to enrich that
experience this is much more than what
you see on the screen here but we're
gonna focus on steps two and a little
bit more in step four when you have a
student that is at your University how
do you help them and how do you deploy
and age it and and not just use ml as a
buzzword how you actually interject that
into the student life cycle to help that
student as they work through your
university and so what you'll see is
dialog flow is really the agent that
enables this very simply dialogue flow
is a conversation building tool and and
it does so in a very powerful way by
using natural language process
saying to take the way that a student or
a professor or a teacher or someone
would speak naturally and translate that
into something that you might have heard
before called intense and and you can
think of that by imagining all the
different ways that someone might ask
about the weather so you know you can
say how hot is it today will it rain
today what's the temperature going to be
like this week and traditionally it may
have been very rigid and difficult for
people to interact with an agent because
it required a very specific input and
it's also very difficult for developers
to create that agent by hard coding very
rigid language in context into that
agent and so what dialogue flow does is
remove that meaning that your user your
student your staff member can interact
the way that we talk very naturally and
all of the natural language processing
that is built into dialogue flow
translates that for you into something
actionable in your body and so today
you're going to hear from three
different institutions and how they've
implemented a lot of this technology and
how they were able to build faster to
inter iterate to to bring in student
input and focus group input to deploy
something very quickly you'll hear about
how the integrations that dialogue flow
presents to you allows you to meet your
student and to meet your staff member
where they are so this means they can
interact on their phones they can
interact in the LMS and the LRS they can
interact in the student portal how
they're used to interacting and you'll
hear about how when you're able to meet
your students and your staff where they
are and how they want to interact how
that really helps you to maximize those
investments not just in technology but
also in the information that you're able
to collect and then give back to your
user base and so with that I'm gonna
bring Greg Reynolds up to the stage to
tell you about how they've done that at
Case Western
Thank You Vanessa hello my name is
Gregory Reynolds I'm an application
developer at Case Western Reserve
University and for those of you that
don't know Case Western Reserve
University is a mid-sized research
institution with lots of undergrad and
grad students that all kind of
intertwine and like all universities we
have a vast amount of information for
our students to consume and our job as
technologists is to bring that
information closer to the students this
saves them time so they can focus on
their learning one of the ways that
we're doing that is through our chat bot
Spartan Answers Spartan answers is built
on the technology of Google assistant
using dialogue flow infused with our
information so the project to create
Spartan answers was a very unique
project for us I
it wasn't a top-down approach like most
projects I write before the second
quarter of 2018 our CIO has asked us
those of us in university technology
that we had interest in chat bot
technologies to just self group so we
did and we had a really good group of
people that decided let's talk about
this let's figure out and we had our own
roadmap we figured out our own audience
and direction to move and we're really
excited about what happened so that all
started around the first part of second
quarter 2018 and within about a month
one of our developers found some code on
github wrote a web application using AWS
and Amazon Lex which worked well as a
paas a prototype but it didn't allow us
to integrate as quickly as we wanted to
with our services and it also didn't
work really well on mobile devices so we
knew we had some work to do so fast
forward to July last cloud next
I met Vanessa and we started talking
about what case wesenrein could benefit
with Google and Google technologies and
then in August Google released Google
assistant to G suite for education which
opened the doors for us to use Google
assistant for our chat bot so I started
exploring how to use that and within a
couple days I had feature parity with
our original prototype and then a couple
more days after that I was able to
integrate with our location information
and our campus events information really
easily this also allowed us to have easy
access on mobile devices because Google
assistant already has an Android and iOS
app so we were very excited about that
and we decided to switch our platforms
to Google assistant and dialogue flow
because of that prototype so in quarter
four of 2018 we started demoing that
project to the different faculty and
staff and our students and the student
focus groups gave us a really great idea
that we were on the right track but they
also helped us build our roadmap for the
future and then in February we released
our product to pilot and we it's been
very well received and we're very
excited about it so I want to talk
briefly about where we're at how we
built it and where we're going next
so to explain where we're at I want you
to imagine that you are a first-time
student your stepping foot on case
westerns campus for the first time it's
August the weather's really nice in
Cleveland Ohio at that time so what is
the first question you as a first-time
student might ask well I know you most
first students first time students would
ask how do I connect the Wi-Fi so you
pull up smart and answers and you ask it
how do I connect to Wi-Fi and if you see
on the screen I it brings up a nice chat
interface in a chat bubble it tells you
the following information and then it
uses the material design dye card view
which also allows for a link that you
can click through for more information
so you know how to get on Wi-Fi so you
turn on Wi-Fi and you're like okay I
need to buy my books so you ask where's
the bookstore so it shows location link
to Google Maps for navigation it shows
the building title and picture so you
know exactly where you're going I and
third eye you might want to know what's
happening this weekend so you ask that
and sure enough it shows a list of the
events happening this weekend so you can
enjoy time with your friends before
classes start so with that I want to
move into how we built it and I know
this might be a little technical for
some people but don't worry there's a
lot of pieces that you don't need to be
a developer to understand and I'll walk
through those as Vanessa mentioned
dialogue flow uses a term called intents
which is just a question-and-answer set
so the so dialogue flows machine
learning can understand what to respond
to a certain question but to get it to
respond with the machine learning you
have to train it and the way you train
it is by giving various types of
questions various types of ways to ask
the question so it can run its machine
learning training on that and so you see
on the screen it says you know how do i
connect to Wi-Fi is there Wi-Fi on
campus and the third one does CWR you
have Wi-Fi and I wanted to point out the
highlight in yellow that cwr you is one
of the many ways that you can say Case
Western Reserve University and so it is
tagged as a university intent our
university entity which allows for
synonyms so this is how we got around
that so we didn't have to train for each
type of way you could ask you know how
do you get to Case Western or whatever
so once you have it trained you have to
tell it how to respond
and if you remember back to the Wi-Fi
question we we had the little chat
bubble that said I found the following
information so in the simple response on
the left that's what's that's where you
input that information and then in the
simple response on the right this is the
audio response that Google assistant
gives and then and the basic card this
is where it shows the material design
card layout with a link and that's all
it takes to do one Question and Answer
intent it's super easy and fast which is
why we really like dialog flow now I
have one more example for you and that's
the location question where is the
bookstore so you'll see that it's the
same type of training and there's a lot
of words highlighted in orange here now
instead of using the synonym approach
with entities we're using multiple
locations as an entity so we can train
one question one intent with all of our
locations and we didn't have to input
every building into dialogue flow so it
makes it really easy once we have a new
building come online which we will hear
in the next few months with our health
education education campus once it's
inputted in the campus Maps database it
will be live right in the chat pod which
we're really excited about that
integration now to do the response for a
question like this it's much different
it's a programmatic way you start with
dialogue flow which is what we've been
talking about but the blue box in the
middle is our web hook and a web hook is
simply a program that you write that
sits in between dialogue flow and other
services and in the red box the service
API for the location information
question that's the campus Maps database
API but we also use it for Google
Calendar I can be any type of service so
once a dialog flow gets the question it
sends that question to the web hook with
the intent name and with the parameters
so in the case of
where is the bookstore it sends the map
intent with the bookstore as a location
so it knows to the webhook knows to talk
to the Google Maps database and the
Google Maps database looks up
information about the bookstore and
passes it on back to the web book which
then packages it up
in a way that dialogue flow can
understand so that is how easy it is to
do both of the types of questions one
that is just simple you give it the
answer and the other that it looks up in
different applications so with that
where are we going next we know we have
a really good start but we know there's
so much more room to grow
we're definitely going to be talking to
our students for more ideas but the few
that we're starting with here in the
next month is our question-and-answer
input tool so even though it's easy to
input questions into dialogue flow it's
not as quick if you have hundreds of
questions to input at the same time so
we're writing using dialogue flow api's
we're writing a tool that will allow our
departments to input hundreds of
questions and then our university
marketing and communications will verify
and approve each question and each
answer so it can all be streamlined and
we can have thousands of questions in
our chat bot up and running very quickly
here in the next few months so the next
two additions are all using the web book
course information just simply any type
of quick information about a course so
where is it what day and time who's
teaching this is something our students
asked for so we're excited to put it in
there and finally the shuttle routes we
don't want our students sitting at a
shuttle stop waiting and waiting for a
shuttle so we're going to be putting in
where is my shuttle
when will the shuttle be at my stop
which will save them a lot of time
so with all of these examples and with
all these additions we are totally
bringing information closer to the
students that way they can focus on
things that are more important than just
finding information they can focus on
their learning with that thank you and
I'd like to turn it over to Daniel
McCarthy he's gonna tell you what
they're doing at Strayer University good
afternoon the company I represent
strategic education we actually have
tuning to universities we have Strayer
University and Capella University and
our student population are primarily
working adults they have jobs during the
day they come in to their coursework all
in line in our learning learning
management system after after hours so
I'm here to talk to you today about
conversational self service and what
we've done at Strayer University at
Strayer one of the problems we were
trying to solve or the problem we were
trying to solve was a volume variance
and availability so we have working
adults they aren't typically able to
make it into the university or call the
University during working hours when
they do make it in or when they are able
to call in they may get bounced from
department to Department and again hold
times wait times and then finally we
were getting more service requests than
we had staff to support so a chatbots
kind of a near perfect solution to a
problem like that a chatbot can be
available at all times of the day 24
hours a day it can handle an infinite
amount of scale and trained properly it
can cross domain boundaries if you think
about this outside of the education
industry for example just think about HR
for a second within HR you might have
of benefits management and then payroll
those are two different domains with
staff that are trained specifically for
those domains and you might have to be
bounced from department to Department
our timeline for the initial release of
our chatbot earthing which was named
after the founder of strayer university
irving Strayer was very compressed
you'll see here roughly six months from
idea to pilot to production and then
scaling what enabled this was a little
bit of a perfect storm
so the those developing this solution
myself included had the domain
experience for the domain that we were
going to hit first the technical
experience and then combining that with
dialogue flow and GCP allowed us to move
very quickly from an idea to a prototype
to production now we'll give you a
little bit of a demo now I apologize I'm
going to start and stop this a few times
so that I can talk through it just a
little bit so I've already stopped it
isn't that disappointing all right so
herbing is available in our student
portal where almost all of our learners
come oh thank you all right so I'm still
going
all right we're gonna go back here and
do this again all right I'll talk a
little bit before we play it curving is
available in the student portal online
the web application we're piloting
Google assistant right now and we're
also piloting us a mass so meeting the
students when they are and where they
are when they are 24 hours a day where
they are whatever platform that they
want to interact with some of those are
a little bit easier than others and now
with that we will play the demo as
students interact with Irving it
recognizes that if they've used
everything before so you'll see here
Holly who is a learner that that is
interested in her academic progress and
completion or progress towards
graduation has used Irving before she
wants to know what classes she has
remaining
Irving goes into our back office sis
system and pulls up her program how
she's progressed through that program
and what she has outstanding now you'll
see here as Holly asks about the
syllabus for a course that she's already
registered for that she's using the
title and this ties into a little bit of
what Gregg was talking about with
entities so we can take the title of a
course we can take the course ID and we
can use those as synonyms and you'll
recognize you'll see in the response
that dialogue flow and Irving have
recognized that critical thinking is
synonymous with phi2 10 and in this case
curving is giving the student to the
link out to the course syllabus because
would you ever deliver a course syllabus
in a conversation in its entirety now
you want to keep things brief and
conversational as you go through that
now Holly's concerned with her GPA so
again we're going to go into our back
office system and pull up that GPA and
see what she's got this is a little
verbose and may need a little bit of
work regarding the response here but
Holly's doing all right with a 3.6 GPA
and she's in satisfactory standing both
academically and
Angela now Holly's asking about her
grades you'll notice that she didn't
give a term schools are term based right
it doesn't matter semesters trimesters
quarters what have you they're
turn-based Irving has contextual
awareness we have set it up such that
curving assumes the most relevant term
based on the time that the question is
asked but we're gonna go through it
again here and again we have entities
Holly asks about grades for fall but
again that's a little bit nebulous is it
fall eighteen or fall nineteen which one
makes most sense
again contextual awareness allows us to
know that we're talking about fall
eighteen and great job Holly for getting
A's and in both your courses now what am
I gonna graduate it's a hard projection
right it's really based on student input
well how well what are you going to put
into it as a student so urban goes
through and looks calculates the average
courses completed per term and then asks
Holly how many she's going to continue
complaining and then we're a quarter
based school so how many quarters
throughout the year are you planning to
attend and from that Irving will then
calculate an anticipated graduation date
and give the projection and a little bit
of legalese for those that require it so
now we'll talk a little bit about
surveying and you'll see here that Holly
is saying thanks and that's a little bit
of an indication that the conversation
is over that the student the user has
gotten what they want from the
conversation and that's rare how many
times have you guys been in a
conversation with any chat within any
chat and just left it when you got what
you wanted I have and that that's the
more frequent case you just leave the
conversation like I'm done I got what I
needed
no thank you or anything like that so we
survey at the time of
conversation conclusion so when we
recognize with a goodbye with a thank
you or something along those lines which
is the rare occasion the other time that
we really survey is when we know that we
have failed to understand the student
and that happens within Strayer when we
have failed sequentially three times
because we really try to understand as
best we can give them as many
opportunities to let us help them with
automation but when we when we fail them
three times
we'll give them a survey and we will
transition if we have availability to a
human agent so that the human agent can
continue that conversation and the human
agent will receive the full transcript
but we're talking about surveys so we we
survey more often when we know we failed
than when we know we've been successful
and as we get into that let's we'll talk
a little bit about those numbers and how
that plays into the survey results so
we've had over 400,000 conversations
with Irvin over 80% of all chat requests
are handled within Irving without
transitioning to a live agent this is
where the surveys come in of those that
have been surveyed by Irving 87% agree
that Irving help them answer their
questions easily now we've gotten some
really good feedback and we've gotten
some negative feedback in there as well
all constructive and will help us
considerably to improve the Irving
experience so Greg talked a little bit a
little bit about it Vaness talked a
little bit about it intense intense or
you can think of those kind of as
topical areas we have 1400 intense and
production right now
now this this this chart is a bit of an
eyesore but I want you to think in terms
of intense this chart shows you over the
past 30 days how our intense have been
used by our student population and look
at that you got twenty or thirty intense
that are receiving the most volume but
you look on the right the longtail look
at that
all other intents represent the majority
of the questions that are answered what
what what you should take away from that
is that the superb service with a
chatbot it's coming on the right for all
of those questions they didn't have to
go somewhere else to get an answer they
were able to get it within even though
the twenty to thirty there are the most
frequently used I'm gonna stop going
backwards I promise so how do we do this
so this is going to be very similar to a
typical software development lifecycle
you got to understand your use case when
you define your use case be very
granular you want you want to be as
specific when you start any
conversational experience as you
possibly can and then you need to gather
data on that conversation how do your
students how do your users ask about
this topic what parameters are they
providing to it what context are they
giving and then you need to script your
conversations and when your scripture
conversations you start with a happy
path the happy path being how you want
them to go through the conversation but
then you need to think about gracefully
handling the fallout the fallbacks
the the branches of the conversation and
allowing for that could that contextual
aid they're going to start developing
your integrations your sis systems your
financial systems your human resource
systems any system and you're going to
test those integrations with dialogue
flow five that's your most important
step you must pilot with your user
population if you do not pilot with your
user population you will get some very
unpleasant surprises when you take this
into any kind of production environment
we we do this regularly at Strayer
University and every time we learn
something new a new way that they ask
about it that we haven't trained the the
BA on or a new use case that we can then
take back to number one and begin
developing again all right so we've gone
one through five and now now we're in
production we can all go home we're done
it's not quite that simple so when
you're in production you need to monitor
your your bot you need to look for
errors with you within your integrations
and more importantly fallbacks within
your conversations and fall bar fall
backs are when the bot can't understand
what the users are sending to it because
within those fall backs that's where
you're going to find that long tail what
do they want to talk to your school
about that's going to that is where you
find this out and then you're going to
keep repeating this until until your you
may be run out of conversations that
have our experiences that you're likely
not going to run out of conversations to
have how do we do this within GCP well
dialogue flow is the system that we use
for the intent detection and entity into
the extraction then we use cloud
functions for fulfillment and
conversation routing we use cloud sequel
to record every interaction that we have
within Irving on a nightly basis we put
that into bigquery so that we can do
some additional analysis and we use data
studio for the reporting there we use
compute engine currently although there
was an announcement today that what may
change that we use compute engine to
post Redis so that we can do count
caching and then we have a custom auto
ml model that allows us to do fallback
classification to better the experience
and since I am already out of time
anyone who wants to hear about that we
can follow up after all of those
components are put together here and
this even this is a little bit high
level on how we combined all of those
components into an architecture that
allows us to serve 1400 different intent
and again I'll be available for a little
bit afterwards if you have questions on
this so where are we going to go next
well this week we are launching at our
sister university capella we're
launching Ella in a pilot phase very
excited about that we're also going to
be increasing the personalization both
within the integrations that we're
developing and the ability to interject
within conversations and maybe not even
wait for a conversation to start now
we're gonna next we're going to go into
our learning management system where our
students spend the majority of their
time to assist them in the classroom
experience completing assignments
writing assistance maybe even quizzes
and then finally phone system
integration so the press 1 for the first
circle of Hell press 2 for the second
circle of hell we're going to replace
that with an integration with Irving so
that you can use natural language to
better the experience and with that I'll
hand it over to neil gomes and you can
talk to you about their experience at
thomas jefferson
I'm gonna be talking to you about the
value of chatbots in the medical space
both for medical and education as well
as you know actually maybe at some point
in the future seeing a chatbot as your
doctor everybody you like that no no I
see some faces saying no okay just you
wait you know maybe it's some Google
next you know we'll be laughing at this
and saying hey you know I said that
you'd see a chatbot as a doc okay all
right well so what I wanted to impress
upon you today is is really the power of
conversation so I'm gonna ask you a
quick question
okay and the answer is not iOS it's not
Android it's not Windows it's not Chrome
what is the best operating system that
we currently understand really well
what's that
the brain really we don't really I I
can't tell what's happening in your
brain right now but what else yeah
language conversation you know the cues
right there okay there isn't much of a
learning curve right and you you don't
you don't need to teach somebody how to
speak usually it after the age of in my
kid my kids case 0.5 they know how to
how to converse and and so so I think
we've been sitting on this for a long
time and haven't really started
leveraging it it's really really
powerful you know and being able to get
machines to start engaging in
conversation is actually a huge leap for
us in terms of you know human
development so so I think that's really
important and we need to understand that
and I work I founded this group called
the dice group or the digital innovation
and consumer experience group at Thomas
Jefferson University and Jefferson
Health where we bring digit
to life that's our motto right and so
we've we've been we've been doing a lot
of work in the chat bot space I'll talk
to you about in a bit but it give you
some context this is who we are
Thomas Jefferson University is the third
fourth Medical School in the nation
almost 200 year old institution we've
heard of terms like gross anatomy Samuel
gross was a Jefferson physician who
started gross anatomy the heart-lung
machine was invented at Jefferson and we
have about 15 hospitals now we've been a
rapid growth kind of phase mode
and-and-and-and on a revenue of about
five and a half billion at this point
but the most important figures sewers
are really those patients you know we
see about 3.2 million patients a year in
our outpatient clinics about 150,000 in
our hospitals and about 550,000 in our
ers okay so and we have about 8,000
students so a lot of impact through some
of the solutions that we create as a
group our team is about 220 people we've
grown from about two when we started
four years four and a half years ago
these are people that are software
developers rob was sitting in the front
here runs a software development team
and we have about 70 or so software
developers we have designers humans and
designers about 40 of them that take
solutions that come to us and then find
what the real problem is and only then
do we develop a solution okay and we
develop several different types of
solutions like this about 130 a year and
return about 10x which is something I
learned about at Google last year in
terms of returns and most of our
projects because we do things very
frugally very frugal innovation and and
we return a lot of value to the
organization just on our digital
solutions we save the organization over
40 million dollars or so put your and
have done a bunch of other things and
sometimes you'd be surprised at what
generates value you know it's amazing
our donation app was generated about one
point four six million dollars just last
month so we never thought that would
happen what we do with digital is we
improve access make it convenient to get
to us offer us to get to somebody else
where they are that's always better and
then provide closed loop
experiences which is very rare in the
healthcare space so so we try to do that
and chatbots and and such types of tools
voice chat BOTS also enable you to do
that and I'll give you a quick example
so voice BOTS right powered by Google
dialog flow we'll be talking about this
on Thursday Rob's gonna do the
presentation we we felt that those
tremendous value to our patients if we
were able to answer any of their
questions at any time while in the
hospital room even though there was no
nurse available on a physician available
so we made a hospital room chat pod
right and and it's voice we got a
speaker system that really worked we
experimented a lot of different types of
speakers you know people stole a lot of
our speakers speaker cables disappeared
and then we came down to this particular
form factor with a company that we work
with and it tells you a lot of things
you know tells you when your meal might
be coming who your doctor is whether
they are both certified or not it will
tell you you know about your disease or
condition it'll it'll give you your
discharge instructions if you're leaving
and narrate them out to you from the EMR
it will control your TV we have mostly
Samsung Smart TVs and so it controls
we've found a channel to do that
controls your TV changes the volume all
of that lighting we can also have it
control HVAC through our building
automation systems all just through
voice so that's that's our voice bots we
found that you know people that agree to
do clinical research they hate the
surveys I mean they're long things they
lie to you at the beginning and say this
will be over in five minutes but it
doesn't get over in five minutes but
they'd rather engage in conversations
sometimes even with a chat pod so we
made some research chat pots for our
researchers and we have the service
available to them to use any time they
want we are now experimenting with the
differential diagnosis chat pod
you know differential diagnosis is you
know whenever you're dark
go to the ER and the doc says or the
primary care and the doc says I'll be
right back
they're gonna check their differential
diagnosis tool okay sometimes that's
called Google but there are actual tools
that that they check that give them you
know they put in your condition your
presenting conditions you know what what
what it seems like you might not
conditions really but symptoms and then
it gives them potential conditions with
you know with probabilities next to that
and it's very very important because
sometimes you might miss something like
Lyme disease for example you know which
presents in a very kind of simple way
you know in an ER many times and you
might just forget to ask that other
question like were you in the woods
recently you know did you get a tick
bite you know those types of things so
it prompts Doc's to ask these types of
questions and it's an extremely useful
tool for learning for residents and
students because sometimes they just
don't realize they've got to ask that
question so they go and do this you know
what if we could present that as a chat
pod almost you know in simple quick and
easy ways right especially because chat
BOTS have these the capability to
present canned responses that they just
tap on versus having to type something
in right so so that's what we are we
experimenting with a company called
Isabel that that creates a great
differential diagnosis tool that's named
after the person's the the CEOs daughter
who passed away because you know a good
differential diagnosis tool was not used
so we also created a along with a with
one of our students once created a a
compendium of all medical school notes
okay
came up with this brilliant idea got
permission from you know the the faculty
and their and their teachers and and
they said it's fine to do it so they
made like a Wikipedia of all medical
school notes and so now we're building
chatbots on top of that because we have
a huge data source to mine we also are
this is very inspiring to see both
examples of student experience chatbots
so this is a space we really really want
to get into
we've we've done some of these things
for patients but not yet in the student
space so that's something we want to
build we've also just deployed recently
appointment chat but the Rothman
Institute which is part of Jefferson and
one of the best orthopedic hospitals in
in the nation now only takes online
appointments through a chat bot okay
24/7 but they do have a phone number you
can call but any online appoints in some
form you just do it via chat pod okay so
and and they're seeing great engagement
and very fast you know information
collection and finally a topic that you
know in the future we're probably gonna
have to deal with and we are doing this
right now is a lot of people especially
institutions like us investing in
robotic process automation right our PA
in the financial side in sometimes even
in clinical deep clinical areas that
have things that happen on the back end
and we like to call these Autobots
because this is you know pointed at
automation and automation platforms and
and we think there's great scope here
because a lot of people that are in the
operational spaces don't understand how
these things work and the boss could
provide that insight you know the bots
could also initiate the next action you
know if you build the right type of
platform you know you can you can do
some of these things
transitionary elements you know really
really effectively using bots we think
because when we go into clinical areas
and we try to with our design teams and
we try to make them more efficient we
find that most latency and most issues
with service happen when something
transitions from one person to another
so now we're starting to automate some
of those transitions right but some of
them are still human so if you want
somebody to respond you know you have a
bot in between that initiates that next
step you know either via a text message
or you know where your platform that you
might have across the system so you know
make things happen a lot faster which in
medicine is very important time is life
many times
[Music]